das ist wirklich eine sensation noch nie
wurde ein so scharfes bild von einem
schwarzen loch gemacht und es ist nicht
wie bisher vermutet das schwarze loch im
zentrum unserer milchstraße sagittarius
stern sondern ein ganz anderes das
zentrale schwarze loch in der fernen
galaxie m87 6 milliarden sonnenmassen
schwer größe 100 milliarden kilometer
eines der größten bekannten schwarzen
löcher so groß ist der ereignishorizont
nämlich hinter dem licht und materie
verschwinden aber sieht man davon etwas
wir liften hier und jetzt das geheimnis
liegt zum science fiction hier gibt's
täglich faszinieren des seins sidos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen zu einem ganz besonderen
moment in der wissenschaftsgeschichte
zeitgleich sechs simultane
pressekonferenzen das will schon etwas
heißen noch mal ganz kurz die grundlagen
eine grundlegende eigenschaft eines
schwarzen loches hat quasi jeder
gegenstand sogar ein atom den schwarz
schild radius von 116 kamen der deutsche
astronom carl schwarz schild auf die
idee dass es bei jeder masse einen
kugelförmigen horizont geben müsse bei
dem die gravitation so groß ist dass
nichts mehr aus dieser kugel entweichen
kann bei allem was wir sehen können ist
dieser radius so klein dass die
außengrenzen des radius des
ereignishorizont so klein sind dass sich
eben die materie außerhalb dieses
horizonts befindet und damit sichtbar
ist bei der sonne beträgt dieser schwarz
schild radios zb drei kilometer sie hat
eine masse von zwei millionen kilogramm
da ist er genauso groß würde also die
masse der sonne auf eine größe unter
diesem radius zusammenstürzen dann würde
ein mini schwarzes loch entstehen das
geht aber nicht da ihr eigengewicht
nicht groß genug ist um die kräfte die
gegen die gravitation wirken zu
überwinden bei sternen
ja mal deutlich schwerer als die sonne
sind passiert das wenn am ende die
fusion im stern zum erliegen kommt und
dieser stern als supernova explodiert
dann wenn dann mehr als die dreifache
sonnenmasse übrig bleibt ist das
eigengewicht so groß dass die
gravitation die krümmung der raumzeit
gemäß der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie sie zu einem
schwarzen loch zusammenstürzen
auch hier noch mal kurz zur erinnerung
masse zieht licht an licht aber eine
feste geschwindigkeit hat kann es nicht
beschleunigt werden stattdessen muss
sich die raumzeit krümmt das ergebnis
gravitation hier werden nach unten
gezogen und umso stärker diese
gravitation ist desto weniger kommen
andere kräfte gegen sie an
zum beispiel die in einem atomkern man
kann sich das so vorstellen dass die
gravitation so stark ist dass auf
unserer erde also wenn man das
übertragen sehen würde berge in sich
zusammenstürzen wir ihnen die erde
gezogen werden es immer und immer
dichter wird dadurch die kräfte noch
stärker werden weil sich die masse auf
eine noch kleinere kugel verdichtet und
am schluss ja am schluss forschungsteam
weltweit vermuten einen unendlich
kleinen punkt im zentrum des schwarzen
loches und was absolut irre ist
wahrscheinlich gibt es auch im zentrum
von galaxien und wahrscheinlich sogar
allen galaxien so ein schwarzes loch nur
ist es riesig absolut gigantisch und
enthält die masse von millionen sonnen
oder milliarden ein super massereiches
schwarzes loch im zentrum unserer
milchstraße
da haben wir ein solches schwarzes loch
gefunden um das zentrum unserer
milchstraße rasen nämlich sterne mit
einem affenzahn der schnellste stern mit
einem tempo von 18 millionen kilometern
pro stunde
alle 15 jahre hat er die runde um jahr
um santa rosa stern gemacht so wurde das
schwarze loch in der mitte unserer
galaxie nämlich gefunden durch die
beobachtung der sterne und so verhält es
sich auch mit der galaxie m87 in ihrer
mitte ist ein riesig ist wirklich
absolut riesiges super massereiches
schwarzes loch mit sechs milliarden
sonnenmassen und das ist das bild dieses
schwarzen loches ist sieht genauso aus
so wie es erwartet worden ist zwar ist
diese galaxie mit mehr als 50 millionen
lichtjahren viel weiter entfernt als das
schwarze loch im zentrum unserer
milchstraße aber eben leichter
beobachtbar da der blick auf das zentrum
dieser galaxie relativ frei ist schon
1918 wurde ein jet aus dem zentrum der
galaxie beobachtet der eben auf ein
aktives schwarzes loch schließen lässt
wenn wir jetzt also das erste bild eines
schwarzen loches sehen dann sehen wir
direkt die wirkung der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie eine
unglaublich starke wirkung der krümmung
von raum und zeit das was wir in der
form der ersten gravitationswellen hier
auf der erde nur ganz schwach gemessen
haben die raumzeit krümmung ist dort
gigantisch und es ist wirklich
unglaublich zum ersten mal in der
geschichte der menschheit sehen wir ein
schwarzes loch und wir sehen die heiße
akkretionsscheibe um das schwarze loch
herum in die materie stürzt die durch
eine geschwindigkeit von etwa 3,6
millionen kilometern pro stunde
unglaublich aufgeheizt wird so schnell
ist nämlich die akkretionsscheibe und
deshalb so hell leuchtet 100 milliarden
kilometer durchmesser hat der schwarze
schatten in der mitte der
ereignishorizont des schwarzen loches
der alles licht und alle materie hinter
seiner grenze verschwinden lässt anton
zensus direktor am max planck institut
für radioastronomie und vorsitzender das
event horizon teleskop leitungsteams
unsere ergebnisse ermöglichen uns zum
ersten mal einen klaren blick auf einen
super massereiches schwarzes loch und
sie markieren einen wichtigen
meilenstein für unser verständnis der
fundamentalen prozesse die die bildung
und die entwicklung von galaxien im
universum bestimmen es ist besonders
bemerkenswert dass sie es in diesem
projekt geschafft haben astronomische
beobachtungen und theoretische
interpretation schneller als erwartet
zum erhofften erfolg zeugen das wirklich
bahnbrechende ist hier auch dass die
vorhersagen wie dieses bild aussehen
würde genau getroffen wurden das ist
wirklich der absolute hammer wir werden
uns sicher noch öfter mit diesem thema
befassen
auch dr watson hat das erste bild eines
schwarzen loches heute zum thema
draufklicken anschauen und doktor watson
natürlich abonnieren bis dann bleibt